Hello Freak bitches,
and I think maybe that guy wouldn't sexually harassed in the big world,
but in this little world where everything's like jammed in together and you have
these clearly defined things like this guy has got a plaque on his desk that
says the boss,
right,
and you got to come in and he's got the desk.
Come on and shut the door.
Shut the door.
Or if you like Matt Lauer,
you've got a button where you lock the door,
click fuck.
Come on.
Inside.
We've got to discuss.
We've got to review your progress.
This click.
This is the world.
I mean,
if mean not exonerating.
Matt Lauer can't believe I to say this again,
but if you're in that guy's world and I don't even know what he did,
I didn't pay attention.
I met him once.
He was quite a gentleman,
but he's in this.
He's got to be working 10,
12 hours a day.
You're doing the today show.
Yeah,
it's insanely competitive.
That morning TV thing,
you have to be on the ball.
You have meetings,
you have fucking stuff to review.
You have guests.
Are you going to review your performance in your conversations with people and.
Well,
Matt,
you know,
whenever you start talking about sex,
people drop off.
Look,
we've got the numbers.
We have the chart in the direct relation to what you were saying earlier is what
I read about Matt Lauer was that,
uh,
he,
he couldn't have sex with just normal people because he's famous and he's,
you know,
he'd get in trouble and he's married.
So he had to maintain the facade of that.
He and he couldn't have sex with other famous people because that would come out
into the press.
So he had to have sex with people who weren't famous.
They weren't just normal people.
And that left the office.
That was it.
So imagine if we lived in a world where we said,
who gives a shit if Matt Lauer's fucking someone other than his wife?
That's between them.
The sixties,
again,
I don't know what that was back when Dustin Hoffman was grabbing titties.
Shoot,
if you guys ever seen,
by the way last.
Sorry,
the last word on this for me anyway,
the people who are acting shocked and outraged around Matt Lauer and Charlie
rose are full of shit.
That's what I.
that's what kills me.
The hypocrisy of the people who have been working with them for years and going,
oh,
I had no idea.
I heard about Charlie rose being a fucking creep 15 years ago and I don't even
work in media.
You know,
it's like the bill cosby thing was open.
The bill cosby thing was an open cab.
If you see,
if you guys seen this is one of,
one of the grossest things you can witness in a workplace is when the boss
starts giving fucking neck back
rubs.
You ever seen that?
A neck rub and boss.
So it is.
It is so fucking creepy to watch a big fat fucking boss saddling up behind some
married secretary.
Just.
Oh,
how are you doing?
The day carol rubbing her neck and we could see the look on her face frozen.
She's got kids.
She,
if she says to him,
Hey,
do you mind?
I don't really want you to touch me right now.
He's going to go,
oh,
I'm sorry,
but then she doesn't know down the line,
down the line when he's doing employee reviews and he's thinking,
you know what room,
that fucking time I just wanted to Robert Back,
man,
but I'm not rubbing any.
That dude's backs in the office now that man that is fucked up and that is one
of the sleaziest slimy as things and to imagine when you're the boss to imagine
that these bosses,
they're oblivious,
they just don't know.
They just want to give them that corrupts.
They're not aware like come on.
They can feel that he's rubbing their back.
If you can't feel their fucking.
Adam's trying to escape your sweaty God damn fucking male.
Dominator.
How many guys become friends with women?
Have Air tag friends just so they just creeping closer.
Almost like your stock and big game and you want to just move real close to and
that's what they're doing.
One of the classics.
That's how I hunt elk.
I walk real slow.
Give it a neck rub.
Try not to make my intentions known,
but Eddie is one of the greatest Jujitsu coaches on planet earth.
It means an amazing Jujitsu coach and Jujitsu competitor,
and one of Eric Dubai's biggest videos is about how Jujitsu is bullshit.
It just shows you.
It does,
isn't it?
About that.
It's like about wing Chung Kung Fu defeats Jujitsu,
which is by the way,
not true.
Don't try it unless you're like way bigger and the guy sucks at Jujitsu.
She got those guys in a room together and they can just spit it out.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
They would just talk about conspiracies to the end of time.
Eddie loves conspiracies.
I would like to talk to Eddie.
We can do that.
He's screaming,
screaming.
Might have to get you some earplugs here tonight.
I said kick him.
He's interesting because he knows so much about them all.
Oh man,
that's really interesting.
Confuses me.
I'm like,
how much time do you have?
Where do you have the time for this?
Yeah.
He's spouting off this,
this advanced physics references,
Mickelson areas failure and things like that,
and it is.
Those are the flatter things.
Yeah,
those science experiments that supposedly proved the.
The wasn't moving.
That one's hilarious to me because when I first brought it up to Eddie,
Jamie pulled this up and send it to me the other day that I first brought it up
to Eddie from like eight years ago on the podcast,
one of the really early podcast when we still did it in my house on a couch and
he's like,
what's the most ridiculous conspiracy theory?
You're hurt?
And I said flat earth,
and he's like,
no,
people don't believe the earth is flat.
So he went from that to not only use 100 percent convinced that it's flat,
but he's definitely willing to listen.
He's down the rabbit hole.
He got sucked in.
He loves it and it's probably like a lot of it is just from him watching endless
youtube.
It's 100 percent what it is.
Here it is right here.
What's the worst conspiracy to like?
The worst one?
Flat Earth.
There's people that are on this flat to the young earth.
That's another bad one.
No,
no,
no.
Like today,
people don't believe that.
That's a big percentage of the Christian population that I went with the young
earth there for fucking stranger.
We're all baked.
So I'd probably,
unfortunately.
But that was,
that was when he found out about flatter for me.
And that was,
you started him down the rabbit thousand episodes ago.
What episode was that?
Fifty four.
So that was probably 2010.
First year.
Yeah.
It doesn't fly.
That was a big on the,
on the Internet back then.
I'm ahead of the curve.
Maybe responsible for this whole thing.
Well,
he and I used to watch ufo things forever,
but he got off a Ufo.
See,
he goes in waves,
right?
Eddie goes in waves,
like we were both like really into Ufo and in particular Zechariah situation,
that was the big one.
I would've said the same thing about bill cosby,
which you have.
Oh,
did I ever tell you this story about bill cosby?
So I dated a girl in like,
oh,
five.
Oh six.
Oh seven.
Uh,
in New York,
beautiful girl,
mixed mixed race.
Um,
and like cool,
whatever.
Great.
And um,
she used to talk about sheep.
Some bill cosby came up one time,
she was like,
oh,
Mr Cosby,
what a sweet man.
And I was like,
man,
what do you,
what do you [inaudible]?
She's like,
Oh yeah,
one time I was on the street crying and uh,
Mr Cosby walked up and introduced himself and was like,
why are you crying?
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
and we struck up a friendship and I was like,
he was trying to fuck him,
just so you know,
I'm just like,
just saying I was trying to fuck you.
She's like,
no,
he was not trying to fuck me.
Like,
and uh,
and,
and like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
no,
it was just like,
again,
like I'm an animal for suggesting it,
like who?
You're so boarish why would you possibly think?
And it's like,
cause I fucking met the guy and he's not a good dude.
Um,
and uh,
and so she,
she defended him,
he used to take me to place just all the shit.
I'm like,
okay.
He just had a long game.
Yeah man.
And uh,
so then all this shit comes up and I text her.
I go,
so what do you think,
what do you think?
You're a boy?
And she goes,
uh,
she said something like,
I think like,
he absolutely did it and I think his wife was in on it,
which again,
I don't know what,
what you meant by that.
But.
So then I,
we're texting back and forth.
He goes,
you know,
one time I was supposed to meet him in Philadelphia and he told me what to wear
and how to wear my hair.
Oh.
And she goes to.
And thankfully I got sick.
She was going to do it.
She was going to wear what she wanted.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was the time.
Yeah.
And set up yet.
And He,
uh,
he,
he was going to take her to the ultimate musical.
Uh,
and she,
and thankfully she got sick and didn't go and I was like,
and the whole time when it's like,
yeah,
that's the thing that one of the things with some of these stories is like,
why would bill cosby want to be friends with some lady?
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
what?
Just because you're great looking.
Yeah.
Well.